children who have been abandoned need
help without international adoptions
more and more children are suffering you
know the law is the law is so ridiculous
gravely
Maribelle Brisa and derek were born in
Guatemala raised by foster gurus for a
year or so and then adopted by American
families in 2007 and he's such a big boy
I love being a mom I love being I'll
learn in Guatemala and we think she's
amazingly special and brilliant but
she's just a normal kid
I mean he's just been the piece that's
been missing for us I can't believe the
blessing that I have had with her
because she's an amazing amazing child
Maribel Brisa and Derek are a few of the
lucky ones there are millions of
children around the world without
caregivers and even at the best of times
adopting a child from another country
can be a long and arduous process you
have to have a psych exam you have to
have a medical exam you have to have
them give them free access to look at
your finances we thought it would take
about six months and ended up taking 13
months so it took about 20 months from
the day that I filled out the
application form to the day that she
came home you got to really want to do
it it is not it's not a lack of wanna
thing you got to want to do it it it's
an expensive process but it's also
taking care of these kids and making
sure they get good homes
I don't think we can imagine our lives
without him I mean it would be there'd
be such a void these families were
especially fortunate because they were
able to complete the adoption process
before Guatemala shut down international
adoptions in 2007 I really had to hold
on lightly because I knew that this
process could stop either because of the
government's closing the doors and she
would be she would end up in an
orphanage or something I'm convinced why
exactly did Guatemala shut down
international adoptions let's rewind
before 2007 thousands of Guatemalan
children found homes abroad each year
thanks to the work of private adoption
agencies and attorneys like Maria who
requested anonymity Maria has been an
adoption lawyer for nearly 20 years
oh I could tell you stories about all of
my adopted children in Qantas and oh
yeah English oh I don't want to say over
the years Maria has helped hundreds of
children find homes and countries all
around the world though that's less
familias all of the families that
receive children from this office they
are happy and healthy children many
Guatemalan children from privately run
orphanages have also found homes with
families of Rowan Madre Ynez of russian
orthodox nun and a descendant of the
founder of the oldest orphanage in
Guatemala has run the Rafaela orphanage
for the past 15 years we have received
over the 15 years about 1,000 children a
little bit more of which 400 have a
little bit more have gone adopted all
over the world well I would say with 95%
success
because well he's a very interesting
story Josue was in the orphanage that
transferred to us a 115 children the
same day and he he had been at that
orphanage since he was a baby and he was
never even on adoption that's how good
the government adoptions work were
working before we took over mother 18's
took over the Isle orphanage in 1995
when a desperate watermelon government
began asking private organizations to
take over its failing state-run
orphanage system when we accepted the
orphanage when we said yes to the
government after a lot of bargaining and
one of the things that we told them is
we'll take over the orphanage but we
don't want your money because we don't
want any strings attached the government
also named us the institution for
adoptions of the country v by 2007 water
Milo's private adoption system is doing
more international adoptions per capita
than any other country in the world
Ola DM pessoa Kresser a partir de llano
the number of adoptions began growing
and growing in 1996 and continued to
increase until 2006 or 2007 when there
were 5000 adoptions Elizabeth Bartholet
is a law scholar at Harvard a leading
expert on adoption and the adoptive
mother of two Peruvian boys enormous
poverty in Guatemala high birth rates in
Guatemala no advice about contraception
or availability and the you know
religious atmosphere in which you know
you're not supposed to use it and
apparently men don't like it and a lot
of reasons that a lot of women were
getting pregnant with babies they could
not raise so lots of reasons for poor
women to think that their best choice
and their child's best choice was
the child for adoption as a mother now
and I don't have any biological children
but I can't imagine anything more
difficult than than giving up and making
that decision even when it's for all the
right reasons once I went to port to
count how many children went through the
through the system through a legal
system of minors abandoned ten thousand
a year it's horrible there are so many
kids that never get adopted and end up
in orphanages or or who knows where and
and that convinced me that a one parent
home is better than no parent home and
it's the best decision I ever made
autumn Allah in many ways seemed to me a
model International Adoption country
which is part of what's ironic because
too many others they saw it as the
target country they should go after
because it symbolized all these terrible
things who exactly would want to attack
a system that was giving several
thousand abandoned children a chance for
a better life each year it turns out
that the most influential organization
that actively works against
inter-country adoptions is UNICEF UNICEF
itself is very careful never to say that
it's against international adoption but
if you look at what they say and do more
importantly at what they do they never
support international adoption and what
they consistently do is attack countries
that are sending large numbers of kids
out they attack what they like to call
adoption abuses entonces encontró que
muchos casos en tu economic we found
that in many situations there was a
financial incentive to participate in
the adoption process that turned the
child into merchandise which went
against the child's rights as a human
being yes there's may be profit motive
but it makes things happen and when you
shut that out you shut things down it's
not about who has more money and what
can we buy him it's more about the love
that we can provide him
and he gives back to us and the family
unit that we've created in a country
with as much crime and corruption as
Guatemala it's hardly surprising that
some people were breaking the law and we
said ok yes there are wrong things going
on but that we have a law so that's
let's apply the law we should prosecute
the people who are violating the law it
is always against the law to kidnap in
addition to concerns about trafficking
and profiteering UNICEF emphasizes the
importance of heritage rights focuses we
important' a book I think it's very
important because a child who grows up
in his own country keeps his culture
values and environment I think there's a
lot of phony Romanticism about why these
kids might be better off in their
country nothing to do with heritage and
you know you look at anybody who looks
at the kids and their real-life
circumstances in institutions and on the
streets these kids are not enjoying
their heritage frontiers don't exist
and when unicef uses the excuse that
people who are from guatemala should
keep their roots and all that junk it's
a lie what people need is family what we
will need is love The Hague adoption
convention is a set of guidelines
intended to protect the rights of
children so on the face of it it's
unsurprising that UNICEF encourages
countries to sign on but however
well-intentioned The Hague might be it's
hard to conclude that the Hague as to
this point benefited the children it was
intended to protect the Hague is has has
been has been a negative influence for a
variety of reasons
um it's used in terms of other countries
poor countries too they're pressured to
ratify it and in the course of ratifying
first of all some of them just don't
have the infrastructure to actually then
create the central authority so they may
ratify but now they can't do what the
Hague requires so all of a sudden now
they can't do international
ultimately in 2007 water molosser come
to pressure from unicef and past an
adoption law intended to facilitate
adoption of the hague convention at that
moment the fates of thousands of
abandoned Guatemalan children changed
kana lakum through the new law suspended
all international adoptions and unicef
was there in congress we had even gone
to Congress many times and their
children to Congress to stop the law and
for many times we were able to stop that
law passing because really the law was
something that was against against the
children it was not in favor of them if
we shut down international adoptions
there's five thousand kids a lot a year
whose lives we are ruining whose lives
could have been wonderful and we are
doing them by shutting them into this
institution so to me that's fundamental
evil in addition to placing a moratorium
on international adoptions the new law
created the national adoption council a
central authority that now controls all
orphanages and adoptions in Guatemala
the law now says that anybody that does
not belong to this office of the
government has is forbidden to do
adoptions so all the children have to
come go through there and all the
parents so it's centralized adoption
okay but doesn't work at all the plan
was to promote in-country adoptions but
that plan hasn't worked since the
high-water mark of 5,000 adoptions in
2007 the number of Guatemalan kids that
get adopted each year has dropped
precipitously routine wine the routine
wanna say we will Concepcion us
according to the National Adoption
Council there have been 35 adoptions in
the past year and now that the state has
taken control Guatemala's once-thriving
system of privately run orphanages is a
thing of the past
oh that arrived at orphanages they're
almost gone an ohio ettus gay
gay whoa the government shut down some
private institutions in some cases they
had to use force other orphanages
decided to close on their own because
they survived on the money they made
from adoptions so when they didn't have
any income anymore they didn't have any
resources to operate that's why they had
to close because the DA phi li y
orphanage is supported by philanthropy
Madre Ynez has managed to keep her
orphanage up and running despite the
government's efforts to take control so
they they came with all these
prohibitions so we told them you know
your law and your contact really is not
in favor of the children so we're not
signing any contract with you yet but
then what are you going to do now
because you you say you are an orphanage
so I told them from this moment on we
are a boarding school
free for poor children the 70 children
still living at the fil aa orphanage are
the exceptions since 2007 abandoned
children have been sent to state-run
institutions like the hogar Isola Dario
Bergen de la Esperanza comenzamos
aproximadamente Co we began with about
300 children and today we have 750 found
in a trash can
there were dogs that were eating her
luckily they started with the umbilical
cord and they didn't cause major damage
so she's she's a healthy girl and they
found him they took a Jo hospital but
she's been here since she was three days
old really early guess em what's going
on it's terrible what are we doing with
the children there is no budget and
before the system didn't cost the
government a penny when kids grow up in
institutions very terrible things happen
to them I mean there are studies and
increasingly good studies now of what
happens to babies if they grow up in
institutions and very quickly in the
first months and years of life those are
enormous ly important periods in a human
beings life when they're very young in
terms of development of the brain
development of emotional capacity we
will not be able to complain that we
have a lot of gangs after because once
they they reach certain age there's no
there you can't go back
there's no way they are to harm to
wounded
el gobierno no puede hacer lo todo
nosotros estamos in total discover ment
can't do everything we completely
disagree with the government
centralizing all activities because in
the first place that's not its function
what you have is people who want to
adopt kids who need homes private
intermediaries yes they often get paid
to put these two willing parties
together I would say I mean if the child
is old enough they're willing party if
they're an infant I think it's what they
would want if they could choose what a
milos new adoption law also contains
regulations that are quite simply
baffling you can't have contact with a
child and you can't have contact with
anyone involved in the adoption process
it is prohibited it's a crime
porque little gossip y'all kick it up
felony no if I want to adopt a child I
can't because I work here precisely okay
why hi mate the COO who worked with
UNICEF to write Guatemala's new adoption
law explains the regulation this way
which oh this is many times a family
that already knows a child might not be
suited to take care of the child's needs
so a study of the child's needs and the
family's qualities must be made that's
why it's important in the adoption
process that there is no previous
contact between the child and the
adopting family The Hague Convention
prohibits it it's not permitted that may
make sense to a bureaucrat but for
parents it's easy to understand how this
kind of regulation could lead to very
bad outcomes we have a child here who he
was badly beaten badly beaten so he
ended at the hospital and these
Guatemalans helped him and they had
their child at the same hospital
so they fell in love with the little boy
finally the little boy came here to this
orphanage so they finally found him
they went to CNA and they said they we
want to adopt him
we know the child we have been visiting
him over all these years so but but the
the case was never clear for us to adopt
so now the CNA maybe we can adopt him
forbidden would you believe that the
situation in Guatemala is not unique due
to pressure from organizations like
UNICEF international adoptions
everywhere are on the decline if you
look at a chart of International
Adoption you can see that for the first
six decades the number of international
adoptions both to this country but also
to other countries went up steadily
almost every single year until 2004 from
2004 to 2010 six years compared to the
previous six decades the number of
international adoptions fell by half you
know I've always held UNICEF in high
esteem but in this situation I'm really
sad to say that I think this was the
wrong move so where do we go from here
the law needs to be more flexible and we
need to reopen international adoptions
definitely as a Guatemalan I am very
proud that there is an adoption law and
that our image of being a number one
exporter of children has changed the
children have dignity water Mullens have
dignity whisky sienna and honey they
give you a demos I would like us to look
at the positive side of adoptions the
positive side of adoptions is giving a
child a family that will care for that
child for its entire life anything that
any of the government's can do to
provide more effectively and less than
the bureaucracy but keep children safe
I'm all for that
and keep the process legitimate I'm all
for that
right they need to do it they need to
take it on and if not then shame on all
of us if you have a program going that
is taking 45,000 children and magically
transforming their lives taking them out
of institutions that will either kill
them or destroy their life prospects
putting them in through loving nurturing
homes and it's at no cost to the
government because the international
adoptive parents pay for it
that's a miraculously successful social
program one day the government is going
to wake up and say how stupid we are now
we're paying to raise all these children
before it was the private people doing
it what are we doing we could have all
those taxes for packets now we have to
spend it on the children well crazy now
let's call on the private people that
have good art and have one to help
orphanages ok have the orphanage we'll
give you the children back that's going
to happen I don't give them four more
years so there's hope
oh yes for the children years poor
children just with the government
there's no hope